KMZ and Wendy's either get together you
guys sign a treaty make a baby live in
Hollywood Freddie
it's your boy Freddy baby [ __ ] Everett I
can we're gonna go to one fast food
restaurant in our favorite food from
there and then we're gonna go to another
bastard restaurant find a food that best
I will make that food that we chose the
poor or them together and make a
masterpiece I'm gonna choose these
fast-food restaurants this bad boy bad
restaurants on the wheel we're gonna
spin them and choose whatever lands
first and looks like we're going to
Manos one more thing we need our lab
swag down Donald what do you like I
usually get my French or you got it 50
McNuggets spin the wheel and stop chip
always chicken mcpaul a do this let's do
it all right what do you like I don't
know well we gotta find something that
complements and McNuggets okay what
makes the mash-up good
complementarianism I gotta work does it
look cool it look why laughs like
Freddie and now we're gonna try this
let's do this alright Bransford rice and
beans yeah that comes before the meat
place the chicken McNuggets inside are
we gonna dice them up nice
but Mozart all right double-team and
there you have it's the Chicken McNugget
Chipotle burrito you know what you like
about this is their branch and both
myself yeah it provides a new element
that I've never had it's pretty good so
where do we go to our next place the
will of steady alright so we'll pull up
on weddings right now and we're gonna
find our favorite ladies item what do
you like Express event they even put up
orange chicken in the frosty a loop it
thank you so much
what do you say when something tastes
really good I think all right so we're
going mister KFC Colonel Sanders
this game came out of a Bill Nye concert
go get em frosty mm-hmm we got the
biscuits let's get the work beastmode
chunk it fly let's go
Wow Cheers oh boy whoa hold up hold up
the biscuits are the perfect texture
this dough plane I just think we should
call it Colonel windy rubra it's pretty
original this is like chicken and
waffles complementarianism Popat our
aesthetic as you dip it and you get like
that coming off it's so good tastes
perfect carving 10:04 we got 39
ok that's almost that's literally almost
perfect masterpiece it's pretty good
absolutely we've got it who's been the
world somewhere fresh a little bit sick
actually I usually get like the Italian
sub with like salami and like cold cold
cut I'm all about that cool card so
Stevens in the car because there's no
parking so I'm gonna go do the dirty
where I think I'm gonna get the spicy
Italian with pickle
go good spin the wheel well we got Taco
Bell you know what I really like
Crunchwrap supreme we're gonna name this
baby we're going back to the office and
put this together back at BuzzFeed
headquarters when we make here we have a
track screen and we have an Italian sub
go get dirty it's aliens up whoops wrong
what kind of meats on it and then we got
the contract and I think we should just
put this whole thing in whoa oh I'll
tell you but from this end you think
about from that is it a range of emotion
too much bread and dough hmm you're
pretty good I feel like it's one of
those things where I'm like no no no
okay rubric personality super super
boring whatever yeah I just wanted more
Crunchwrap I think this looks pretty all
right and then taste I give it a three
I'm instead you know I'm gonna end on a
bang I just [ __ ] like they're the last
arrived how do you think today went old
speedy old pal yeah we put the six
places in three hours it's a business
process the biscuits with the frosty
with my favorite I feel like a mad
genius okay so until next time what do
you want to do next
get your boys deep inside now
you